here's noted black lesbian press
secretary Corrine John Pierre just lying
about what's going on here the president
inherited a mess
the president inherited a mess these are
the same exact people who every time
Donald Trump said we have to have a
border and then we can figure out what
to do with the dreamers meaning the
people that are here the young people
who were born here and everything else
and a pathway to citizenship and we've
covered this many times Biden sorry
Trump was willing to negotiate with the
Democrat everyone knows it like you
without even knowing all the specifics
you know that when Donald Trump was
President he would have cut deals to
deal with the immigration situation and
deal with the people who are here
already and the dreamers and everything
else right there's been a lot written
about this the Democrats Chuck Schumer
is on the record saying they did not
want to give him a win right they did
not want to cut a deal with Trump
because they did not want Trump to be
good to be thought of as positive and
they certainly did not want him to be
reelected well uh Nikki Haley who was
Donald Trump's U.N secretary right the
ambassador to the U.N from the United
States and then also of course was the
governor of South Carolina she heard
what Corrine Jean-Pierre said and she
tweeted this out so she's you can see
she's retweeting the original video that
we just played right there and she said
here's the border crossing mess that
Biden inherited in 2020 458
000 uh illegal people crossed over in
2022 I'm not a math the magician but
it's about five times that two point
roughly 2.4 million people don't listen
to this Administration spin when Biden
goes to the Border tomorrow the mess
he'll see is one he created and of
course that is true and that is why we
must fight the media lives and that's
why we must not forget what they did to
Donald Trump and the way they treat him
versus what they are doing and the way
they now treat with kid gloves the
elderly man pretending to be president
[Music]
foreign
[Music]